what's your relationship with lsf do you
ever read it yeah I I do it in the same
way
people arm like yeah yeah to feel
something just
after you put on a big event and you
risk all your financial money let me
feel really good about myself and you
read live stream fails no yeah after
this stream rewards that's when I sent a
message I was like ban
genuinely it used to be something that
you like looked forward to sure really
like I remember because some some of my
very first Clips were on lsf and lsf
made me or whatever but you'd see these
clips and everyone would be like so nice
right and it almost do you have you ever
heard about that that Art Exhibit where
that woman stood there for an hour like
unfazed or something like people could
walk in it was just her standing there
and there was feathers and silk and
there was also a gun with one bullet and
stuff like that and they could interact
with her however they wanted and at
first people were nice they'd like kiss
her on the cheek or they'd give her a
hug or they would you know something
just like sweet and then eventually
people started undressing her people
took a knife to her and cut her people
held the gun to her head well she just
stood there and stopped and the whole
point of the exhibit was to talk about
humans and how they naturally divulge
into [ __ ] evil and I feel like that's
what lsf has done yeah it's so sad like
it's become a a Reddit that thrives off
of streamers and now they hate streamers
yeah and it's it's just sad yeah it's
just after the streamer Awards it was so
bad that yeah I asked to be banned and I
banned me for a little bit and then you
mean asking to be banned so go on it
yeah exactly so you'd ask to be banned
so they couldn't post your Clips on it
they couldn't talk to you talk about you
on it why can't they post your Clips
like if your name is banned right yeah
you as like so if anyone puts cutie
Cinderella oh I see you asked the mods
to yeah yeah so you can't be on the
Reddit and they were like okay but then
a lot of people asked for it and then
they were like never mind wow they got
rid of the band system so now it's so
sad because even one of my one of my
purposes with the streamer Awards is
streaming doesn't have a way to pull
everyone from every corner of the
internet and yeah lsf was one of that
one of those Corners that I was trying
to be like look guys we've done
something like this for us and they were
they were livid they're like oh this is
gonna fail No One's Gonna watch it like
LOL yeah damn when I was streaming I
would you know just have some stream and
then my friends would go yo you're on
lsf and I would just my heart would sink
and I don't know I don't want to know
dude nothing like no no it's fine it's
fine yeah I've skated by it just a
couple times on lsf and I've been all
right they haven't put the gun to my
head yet but I was just curious yeah I I
didn't imagine that you were a lot or
anyone really read that [ __ ] anymore no
I mean like the saddest thing was is I
had the stream Awards it was a very
successful event and I go home because
I'm exhausted and I knew because Ludwig
won streamer of the year yeah I knew
that was going to be an issue people
that were like oh cutie rigged it you
think I would rig it from my boyfriend I
think I would be like oh that's the most
obvious yeah yeah what the hell no right
before they announced like it's so sad
because there's this chunk of me that's
like really proud girlfriend because he
did a lot like yeah yeah this year he
objectively yeah he's done a lot I would
say just even like just a couple years
in total and it almost seems like people
forget that and other YouTubers last
year was his like subathon right yeah
that was like the biggest thing ever was
that not two years ago my memory is like
so [ __ ] right now 21 wasn't it 20 21
yeah so the award show in 2022 is 14.
okay yeah why did I think you did a
subathon during like covet like 2020.
still kind of coveted it was like March
okay 21 yeah that whole period is such a
blur to me anyway three years yeah so
right before it's announced I'm sitting
backstage with Maya and I give her my
phone said I don't want to see it yeah
so I I hadn't had my phone until that
night and then finally the dumb ass that
I am I I get on lsf and I cried damn
like I sobbed my heart out and I was
like this is so sad that I just did this
thing that was like the whole purpose of
it was to be positive streamers I know
like everyone's like oh millionaire
babies that stay at their house we also
we don't get recognized enough for like
the hard work yes we get a five dollar
sub from somebody and that's amazing and
that's great but like there's nobody
there's no boss patting you on your back
saying no good job you're a gold star
like yeah I know it's silly but being
recognized in life is pretty important I
think to understand Christianity I think
it's uncomfortable too sorry to ask you
off I think it's uncomfortable because
when you are Your Own Boss it it's so
like weird to validate yourself oh my
God yeah and the whole internet
especially streamers I mean the whole
internet is telling you sometimes even
your own chat like hey yeah shut the
[ __ ] up like you know like you don't
work at all you know so yeah sorry
continue no you're good like every
single day there's somebody in your chat
being rude to you at least every five
minutes yeah and so yeah let me give you
a stupid gold trophy yeah but like asmen
gold who's been a World of Warcraft
streamer for years when I told him he
was nominated he said to me he's like
I've never won anything this guy who's
just like this a pinnacle of a part of
the platform yeah are you kidding me
yeah just making content like all the
time so you would think that you know a
Reddit dedicated to streamers would be
excited about this but no they were it
was only the negatives and of course I
know like whenever I do an event people
think like the first thing you should do
is celebrate the first thing I do I pull
out my phone and I write down everything
I'm changing next year that's the first
thing yeah do you have a team that helps
you like organize or is it just you it's
just me right now I have two assistants
that I got recently and they're starting
to help but yeah it's hard that's where
I that that Gap comes from that a lot of
people don't realize it's like I'm not a
buy I'm not Ludwig has a team of like
20. yeah 20 people yeah holy what is
that they're so talented he has he has a
personal assistant he has like someone
that does the merch he has someone that
does all of his filming within the
filming there's someone that does like
the photography and then he has like a
set designer pretty much on payroll and
then he has like his manager and then he
has and these are all people on his
payroll it's not like Partnerships with
outside companies no these are all on
his payroll he is a huge staff it's it's
really really cool but that's not
something I'm a 4 000 viewer streamer
yeah like but it sounds like your event
thing could be something bigger yeah it
could be like a eventually if I start
profiting off of it then yeah I can hire
people but for now it's very much like a
gorilla effort where it's just like here
we go like me and my assistant were at
my house yesterday and during [ __ ] Camp
we're doing Zorb soccer soccer let's go
that is what is that are you are [ __ ]
kidding human Zorb soccer yeah you are
nuts it's like those big
bin too besides their feet are out yeah
and so run around and Play Soccer oh
that's sick yeah oh my God it's gonna be
an issue I think someone we gotta do we
gotta sure get hurt yeah a bunch of
streamers yeah someone's gonna get hurt
sorry I was exaggerating a little bit of
my reaction was so exaggerated because I
thought you were doing the ones where
you're no feet I thought someone was
gonna be in it it'd be really hard to oh
they were the ball yeah and I thought
yeah sorry yeah I was like that's that
thing that killed that person on that
Russian flew off
100 degree heat inside a ball yeah that
would just be sacrifice whoever went in
that's mid-summer too right there yeah
that should be the crescendo of [ __ ]
camp at the very end the very last day
we start humming yeah xqc get in yeah he
has to add us all to his Auto host first
X would die yeah
um but we absorb soccer and so I bought
all these Zorb balls yeah thinking
nothing of it and then they show up and
I have 12 50 pound boxes outside my door
and it's just me and my assistant and
she's like she maybe weighs 100 pounds
and where I'm staring at these and I'm
like how are we gonna get these yeah
weird things like that is where I make
mistakes where it's always like me and
my assistant loading everything in and
loading everything out and I'm like we
really need help next time but again I
don't make money off these events yet so
if you even have like a truck or
anything no I have a Subaru like it can
do a lot but mostly get me women yeah
we got a lot of lesbian listening yeah
listeners right now they're like I don't
know why I'm flirting with you natural I
guess